[Musique]
une maison coloniale des beaux quartiers
de shanghai
un jeune couple écoutent attentivement
les conseils d'une organisatrice de
mariage vous allez tenir la coupe comme
ça par le pied oui très bien comme ça
c'est plus joli
après avoir bu le champagne
vous allez remonter sur scène tout
doucement s'ils prennent des cours de
protocole c'est que leur mariage
s'annonce fastueuse fifi le futur mari
est un financier millionnaire de 24 ans
il a déboursé pas moins de 30000 euros
pour cette formation d'une heure et
demie vous la marée vous vous blessez
juste un peu et vous aimeriez vous
avancez le pied gauche
vous vous approchez d'elle la main comme
ça oui c'est ça et vous enlevez
doucement son voile vous la connaissez
vous la caresser doucement
ensuite vous l'a relevé et puis vous lui
faites un v6 et vous la mariée vous
tournez votre visage vers l'extérieur
oui comme ça
1 2 3 c'est très bien quinze jours plus
tard nous retrouvons la mariée en robe
rouge à quelques heures de la cérémonie
elle s'appelle bibi elle a 24 ans elle
n'est pas financière mais employés de
banque et filles de paysans
bibi va bientôt réaliser le rêve de sa
vie n'ont pas trouvé le grand amour mais
épouser un millionnaire
ce sont des diamants et du cristal deux
soirs au ski hier soir j'ai passé plus
de deux heures à les arranger
c'était long mais ce n'est rien par
rapport à tous les efforts que j'ai fait
pour me trouver un mari sept ans
d'efforts pour conquérir un homme
fortuné rencontrés au lycée les amis
d'enfance de bibi sont très envieuse se
trouvent des ongles vous êtes jalouses
les filles
oui oui je trouve que son mariage est un
mariage de rêve de toutes nos copines
bibi est la première à avoir réussi et
en plus elle est super jeune
réussir dans la vie ce serait donc pour
ces jeunes chinoises se trouver un mari
riche
ce nouveau type de femmes qui assument
leur matérialisme porte un nom les
pêcheuses de millionnaires et des
millionnaires la chine on compte 1
million justement quatre fois plus qu'il
ya cinq ans nous avons suivi djadja une
jeune très deux très déterminés qui
chasse le millionnaire à plein temps et
xao chan une vendeuse qui est allé
jusqu'à divorcer pour se consacrer
entièrement à sa quête d'un bon parti
enquête sur une chine où l'amour semble
être devenu un investissement
[Musique]
un samedi à shanghai sur la promenade du
bund dans le quartier de l'exposition
universelle dans sa robe de haute
couture française une jeune femme semble
craindre le soleil elle tient à la
blancheur de sa peau djadja 25 printemps
se rend à une foire aux célibataires
des centaines d'hommes et de femmes
entre 25 et 35 ans se relayent autour de
grandes tables chacun espère trouver
l'âme soeur
le principe enchaîné les entretiens
pendant seulement huit minutes et glaner
un maximum d'informations sur les coeurs
à prendre
diageo a attaqué bille en tête tu gagnes
combien je gagne 600 euros par mois
désolé mais je cherche quelqu'un qui
gagne plus que moi tu sais je gagne
quand même de 1500 euros par mois soit
10 fois le salaire moyen chinois
dia dia semble agacer deuxième et c'est
peut-être une meilleure pioche
la société elle est cotée en bourse où
ça exactement à shanghai ou dans le sud
à shanghai
ok ça va alors et combien tu gagnes
combien je gagne un dépôt je sais que ça
dépend mais à peu près
environ trente mille euros par an ah oui
d'accord tu ne gagnes pas plus que moi
quoi autrement dit une perte de temps
djazia ne passera pas une minute de plus
dans ce repaire de pauvres gens
je pense que leur salaire et leur niveau
de vie ne correspondent pas du tout à
mes attentes
elle décide alors de tenter sa chance à
un grand jeu organisé dans ce pavillon
juste à côté de la foire aux
célibataires
le principe ce charmant jeune homme un
artiste plébiscité par un jury pour ses
qualités physiques doit désigner sa
princesse parmi pas moins de seize
jeunes filles son look d'homme joyeux
lui vaut beaucoup des logements merci je
suis quelqu'un de très optimiste dans la
vie parmi les candidates c'est sur dja
dja et sa beauté froide qu'il jette son
dévolu
mais voici ce que l'heureuse élue va
répondre aux héros du jeu qui l'a fait
gagner
je cherche quelqu'un qui a réussi sa
carrière plus que toi je n'admire que
les hommes qui réussissent parce que moi
j'aimerais bien être femme au foyer pour
ne pas avoir besoin de travailler elle
m'a jeté mais je ne lui en veux pas je
comprends qu'elle cherche un meilleur
profil tu es quand même un peu triste
oui oui je suis un peu déçu tu la
trouves trop matérialiste
non c'est normal que les femmes
cherchent la sécurité financière
non
si dja dja et conduit les prétendants
avec autant d'assurance c'est qu'elle
croit dur comme fer en ses chances de
trouver l'homme millionnaire et en chine
aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas seulement les
femmes aisées comme elle qui consacrent
leur vie à cette quête
toutes les classes sociales sont
touchées par le phénomène
un quartier pauvre dans la banlieue de
shanghai xau chan une femme élégante de
49 ans rentre chez elle elle est
vendeuse dans une quincaillerie
elle gagne 300 euros par mois à peine
plus que le salaire moyen qui est de 250
ce quartier est très délabré j'aimerais
bien partir aujourd'hui les logements
sont hors de prix à shanghai shao chan
élève seul son fils évite aussi avec son
père dans un petit appartement ils
dorment et mangent tous les trois dans
cette pièce de 8 mètres carrés alors
c'est ici que vous vivez we say die si
c'est pas terrible
xau chan s'est séparée de son mari il ya
deux ans pas à cause d'une crise
conjugale il s'entendait plutôt bien si
elle l'a chassé du foyer c'est pour
pouvoir s'adonner à plein temps à sa
nouvelle vocation devenir fan de
millionnaires liront j'ai divorcé de mon
mari parce qu'ils ne gagnaient pas assez
d'argent
il était trop pauvre et la vie est dur
c'est de trouver un millionnaire et
qu'il m'achète un logement dit censure
votée comme ça que je peux profiter de
la vie c'est sa maîtresse
c'est pour ça que je dois me faire payer
tous les mois
xao chan dépenses la moitié de son
salaire dans des soins de beauté à
presque 50 ans elle sait que la
concurrence est rude chez les pêcheuses
du millionnaire son divorce est un pari
sur l'avenir
bonjour bienvenue
une fois par semaine pendant une heure
et demie elle s'offre une séance de
soins hydratants la directrice du centre
veille à ce que xau chan garde confiance
en elle comment elle s'appelle déjà
celles qui portent des chaussures anvers
et cendrillon oui c'est ça tu vois
cendrillon quand elle balaie les rues
le prince ne la regarde même pas mais
quand elle s'arrange
elle réussit à séduire les millionnaires
elle entre dans la cour des grands et la
cour des grands justement xau chan a
bien l'intention de la voir de près ce
soir elle a eu vent d'une soirée de
rencontres entre célibataires fortunés
elle a décidé de s'y inviter
au risque de passer pour une intruse
lui il est trop beau la lui à gauche
mais il est vraiment trompeur
au programme de la soirée un jour de
découpage et de collage pour favoriser
la communication entre les coeurs
solitaires xau chan reste à l'écart
visiblement embarrassé devant elle
les riches participent ans adresse la
parole et s'amuse de leurs oeuvres
finalement nous à auch en va surmonter
sa jeune et se lancer moi je suis
quelqu'un de très timide
pardon c'est normal c'est une femme une
femme chinoise doit être timide où
travaillait en quoi et quel type de
femme recherchée
je sais pas j'ai mes critères mais les
femmes ont leurs critères aussi ça ne
coïncident pas tout faux
alors elle vous plaît pas vraiment les
femmes de plus de 40 ans sont trop âgés
pour moi en fait elles ne sont petits
très actives sexuellement
vous êtes déçu que ça aux charges non
c'est normal qu'ils cherchent une femme
beaucoup plus jeune commande et pour
trouver des femmes jeunes
les millionnaires font appel à des
agences matrimoniales spécialisées elles
sont de plus en plus nombreuses
le mariage des hommes fortunés devenu un
business en chine principales enseignes
lagence one chip
elle emploie 600 personnes dans tout le
pays devise de la maison
le mariage est le plus gros
investissement de la vie aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de chasseuse de têtes
travaille sur une commande passée par un
millionnaire il ya quinze jours
bonjour tout le monde
nous ne pourrons pas le rencontrer il
tient à rester anonyme il donne un
million d'euros pour trouver la perle
rare et il est exigeant la directrice va
briefé ses troupes avec un langage
direct en prenant un exemple son nez et
sa dentition ne sont pas parfaits donc
concentrez-vous sur sa bouche sa bouche
non plus n'est pas très joli en fait si
vous regarder de loin elle est pas mal
mais de près vous voyez ces dons ne sont
pas belles nous ne pouvons pas classé
cette fille dans la catégorie à
il faut l'a rétrogradée en catégorie b
faut qu'elle soit grande qu'elle est la
peau douce qu'elles soient diplômés mais
de bonne famille
elle doit mesurer à m 67 ou 1 m 68 ou un
mètre 69
c'est au centimètre près il n'y a pas de
marge possible sur comment lagence
répond-t-elle à cette commande en
traquant la perle rare dans la rue les
vins chasseuse de têtes prospects dans
quatre villes de chine à pékin liu jin
est l'une d'entre elles dans le milieu
elle est célèbre pour son taux de
réussite son surnom la cupidon chinoise
sa technique arpentait les quartiers
branchés et poursuivre les jolies
passante
tu es célibataire et crie ton nom ici
c'est tout va bien on pourra te
présenter à des hommes qui ont une
fortune personnelle de plus de 600000
euros à lessines ici s'il te plaît
bonjour mon job c'est de repérer les
belles filles comme vous dans la rue
vous êtes célibataire chemin
non mais ça ne nous intéresse pas en
attendant vous avoir dérangé
je dois chasser le but de remy cinq
filles pour cette grande parmi ces 800
filles jeunes représentant que 20 aux
clients on ne sélectionne que les plus
belles filles pour les millionnaires
parmi les beautés repéré par yong shin
une certaine djadja l'attrait 2 de la
foire aux célibataires
elle a été approché il ya six mois avant
la commande du millionnaire mais elle
est encore dans la base de données de
lagence djadja passe aujourd'hui un test
d'évaluation pour savoir si elle
pourrait plaire aux fameux client quel
est ton genre d'homme je n'aime pas les
gros je n'aime vraiment pas les groupes
j'aime bien les entrepreneurs les pdg
si tu tombes sur un homme qui a une
mauvaise hygiène comment tu réagis
je pense que je suis une fille tolérante
je vais essayer de le faire changer
mais si je n'y arrive pas je peux
m'adapter alors elle a réussi à l'examen
dja dja est une fille tolérante et mûre
elle a réussi le test face à ces accords
je pense qu'on va la présenter au
millionnaire
sauf qu'il y ait un problème djadja
mesure 1 mètre soixante et onze deux
petits centimètres de trop pour le
commanditaire
l'attrait 2 est donc hors course elle
reste toutefois dans les petits papiers
de lagence camp pour ces jeunes filles
trouver un mari fortuné devient plus
important que leur réussite
professionnelle
quelle est la position de leurs familles
retour à shanghai devant la maison des
futurs mariés bibi et fifi le marié
arrive avec la voiture de luxe qu'il va
offrir à sa future femme
un cadeau d'un million d'euros
[Musique]
à sa sortie il est accueilli par ses
amis de la jeunesse dorée de shanghai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'ensuit un cérémonial dans la tradition
chinoise
qu'on soit riche ou pauvre le marié doit
offrir du thé à ses beaux-parents et les
beaux parents répondent en servant un
bol de soupe au jeune couple
un rite d'acceptation mutuelle pour bibi
d'employés de banque et pour toute sa
famille des paysans
c'est un très grand joueur
[Musique]
nous nous l'avons soutenu pendant toutes
ces années
et finalement elle est arrivée à trouver
quelqu'un de bien c'est surtout une
fierté familiale
quel rôle les parents de ces jeunes
filles subtil exactement exerce-t-il une
pression un dimanche à shanghai dans le
parc du peuple tous les week-ends des
milliers de personnes se pressent dans
cette gigantesque foire aux hommes
riches
ces derniers ne sont pas présents mais
affichent leur revenu sur des petites
annonces mais mädchen 65 ans vient ici
seuls chaque week-end depuis trois ans
cette femme au caractère bien trempé est
prête à tout pour marier sa fille de 30
ans par exemple lui il est intéressant
mais ma fille est trop âgé pour lui
oui ils gagnent 50 mille euros par an
mais il n'est pas du clos mais donc ça
ne va pas tiago s'est même et chaîne
elle même qui a pris l'initiative de ces
prospections sur le profil de son futur
gendre elle est intraitable
il doit posséder un bel appartement à
shanghai
pourquoi le logement était aussi
important parce que je ne veux pas que
ma fille mène une vie de vagabonde
il y a autre chose aussi
il ne doit pas manger de chiens ou de
chats parce que ma fille adore les
animaux et pourquoi est ce que c'est
vous qui cherchez un millionnaire est
pas votre fille parce que ma fille n'a
pas le temps et en plus elle est timide
mais mitchell est une mère moderne elle
a intégré les nouvelles valeurs de la
jeunesse chinoise
quand elle était jeune les femmes ne
courais pas après les hommes riches
d'ailleurs il n'y en avait pas c'était
une autre chine à mon époque on aimait
les hommes qui aimez la littérature
moi si mon mari m'a séduite c'est parce
qu'il connaissait la littérature
française et en particulier la dame aux
camélias même etienne a bien changé et
aujourd'hui pour rien au monde elle ne
me marierai sa fille un professeur de
français ni même un écrivain elle la
retrouve pour une séance de manucure
elle s'appelle evening et surprise elle
ne partage pas du tout les idées de sa
mère je ne veux pas que tu meures de vie
de vagabond droit de décider pour moi
la jeune célibataire n'a rien d'une
pêcheuse de millionnaire elle est à
contrepoids
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ma mère moi
je ne regarde pas le niveau de vie je
m'en fiche du changement pour une jeune
fille comme moi ce qui compte ce sont
les sentiments dans une relation
c'est l'amour qui est plus important
comme li ning de nombreux chinois se
montre gêné par cette mode matérialiste
au premier rang desquels les dirigeants
communistes ils aimeraient enrayer ce
qu'il considère comme un déclin des
valeurs morales cette jeune mannequin on
a fait l'expérience à ses dépens elle
s'appelle ma nuo elle a 24 ans il y a
deux ans elle participait à une émission
de télévision le tournez manège chinois
son intervention a été très remarquée
[Musique]
mano est ce que tu veux venir rire avec
moi sur mon vélo
si dans ce non je préfère pleurer l
arrière d'une bmw
elle préfère pleurer à l'arrière d'une
bmw tout cas d'être heureux sur un vélo
une réplique jugée trop provocante par
le gouvernement qui a effacé les
archives
l'extrait n'est plus visible que sur
quelques sites internet après cette
censure le discours de mano a changé
c'était une plaisanterie
si j'avais su que cette phrase aurait
fait un tel bruit
j'aurais tourné cette fois malandra
bouche malgré elle manou est devenue une
icône générationnel et cet institut de
sondage à pékin a pu constater que les
pêcheuses de millionnaires sont
désormais un phénomène de société
il vient de publier une étude qui a fait
grand bruit
80% des chinoises refuserait d'adresser
la parole à des hommes qui gagnent moins
de 450 euros par mois
cet analyste en tire des conclusions
pessimistes
les chinois ne comprennent pas l'amour
en fait il leur manque la capacité
d'aimer la société chinoises encouragent
la compétition professionnelle et dans
notre pays il n'y a pas d'éducation
sentimentale et tout cela se retrouvent
amplifiées par le développement
économique effréné de la société
chinoise réussir à tout prix dans les
affaires et dans son mariage
nous retrouvons djadja dans un avion
pour shanghai lagence jointe chili lui a
payé le billet pour participer à une
soirée privée avec des millionnaires
cela se passe à pudong un quartier
d'affaires
ce soir elle gravir un nouvel échelon et
cela lui tourne un peu la tête dans les
grandes villes comme pékin ou shanghai
c'est vraiment trop banal de sortir avec
un millionnaire qu'est ce que tu entends
par banal tu cherches quel niveau de
fortune ou moins 10 millions d'euros
et pour en faire quoi comme ça ça m'a
sur un confort matériel à moi à mes
parents et à mes futurs enfants
mais 10 millions d'euros de revenus oui
enfin je compte le salaire et les biens
immobiliers
une fois
[Musique]
la soirée commence dix filles ont été
envoyées par l' agence
chacune reçoit un numéro pour elle
l'objectif est clair ramener un
millionnaire à la maison ils sont
également dix numéros téoz aussi ils ne
veulent pas être filmée par souci de
discrétion
les concurrentes vont devoir faire leurs
preuves en dansant et en chantant les
unes après les autres devant le groupe
des hommes elles jettent toutes leurs
forces dans la bataille
[Musique]
je
hahaha
[Musique]
oh
jean
autour de l'âtre à 2
bonjour je m'appelle jihadia je viens de
loin de mandchourie
elle va tout miser sur une chanson
d'amour mélancoliques peut-être pas le
meilleur choix j'aurais plus chanter
mieux applaudissements timides jogia n'a
pas vraiment convaincu
qu'importe à tout en tentant de
conquérir un banquier et elle va se
montrer beaucoup plus charmeuse que
l'autre jour à la foire aux célibataires
je travaille dans la finance
c'est super bien et toi tu travaille
aussi dans la finance oui en fait je
suis très 2
j'aimerais devenir analyste financière
malgré tous les efforts de jah jah le
financier en restera là
pas d' échange de numéros de téléphone
nouvel échec
mais elle n'aura pas perdu sa soirée un
coach rencontrés sur place va lui donner
une idée pour être plus efficace dans sa
quête
je t'explique champagne c'est le nom
d'une région en france en dehors de
cette région on appelle tous les vins
des vins mousseux et non pas champagne
et comment je dois tranquille tu fais
comme ça comme ça voilà tout à fait il
me faudra du temps pour m'initier à la
culture du vin mais j'ai bien
l'intention d'y consacrer le reste de ma
vie ça peut être ma passion je suis sûr
que je vais aimer ça si dja dja est prêt
à se donner les moyens de réussir xau
chan la divorcée doit faire avec le peu
d'argent dont elle dispose
dans son quartier pauvre de shanghai
elle a un rendez vous
[Musique]
vous allez vous xao chan je vais aller
chez le voyant et pourquoi vous savoir
si j'arriverai à trouver a millionaire
la séance de voyance va avoir lieu dans
cet appartement
c'est la première fois qu'elle a recours
aux services de cet homme voyant ça fait
15 ans que je suis dans le métier je
n'ai jamais échoué
assieds toi la donne moi ta date de
naissance je suis né le 26 mars 1963
c'est l'heure à quelle heure tu ne sais
pas calendrier lunaire ou solaire je ne
sais pas cla
du pense que je vais trouver un
millionnaire ou parle
donne moi ta main
agir c'est dommage si tu t'étais
intéressait la littérature un peu plus
tôt dans ta vie tu serais déjà la femme
d'un millionnaire je peux voir que tu as
un grain de beauté où ça courait dans le
dos et pas n'importe quel grain de
beauté
il porte bonheur dans quelques mois
tu vas rencontrer quelqu'un de très
riche si tu ne le trouve pas reviens me
voir je te rembourserai je suis très
contente
il m'a promis le bonheur photo là pour
bibi et fifi le bonheur c'est maintenant
la cérémonie va commencer dans moins
d'une heure
bibi vient de recevoir de son futur
époux des bijoux en or et en diamants
mais l'employé de banque qui s'habitue
très vite au luxe va se montrer
exigeante
regarde-moi pas que tu m'a offerte
elle est trop grand pour moi
entretien
mais ces boucles d'oreilles me font mal
et ne penses tu vas tu es habitué
non ça n'arrête pas de me faire mal je
t'ai dis que tu vas t'y habituer le
mariage est célébré dans cet hôtel 5
étoiles où 500 personnes les attendent
coût 2 millions d'euros pas de prêtres
mais un animateur une dizaine de
photographes et de cameramen
professionnels les moyens sont ceux
d'une chaîne de télévision
la cérémonie est chronométré
[Musique]
le son
bibi et fifi répète tous les gestes
qu'ils ont appris avec succès
c'est l'heure h mad'moiselle bibi qui
voulez vous prendre monsieur fifi pour
épouse oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et le voilà ce geste qui fait rêver des
millions de chinoise elle vient de
mettre la bague au doigt d'un
millionnaire
[Musique]